أجانب ،
نحن محظوظون جدًا لأن لدينا
علاقات مهمة وتاريخية مع أصدقائنا
وحلفائنا بين دول الخليج ،
ونتطلع إلى الأمام ما نريده هو
علاقة حديثة مبنية ليس
فقط على تعاوننا الدفاعي والأمني ​​التاريخي
ولكن أيضًا تعزز
اقتصادنا.
أجنبيًا ،
كان هناك اتفاق تم طرحه على
الطاولة في مارس لم تنتهز إيران
الفرصة للمضي قدمًا
وأعتقد أن الوضع الآن
صعب للغاية وعلينا التفكير
في أفضل الخطوات التالية مع
شركائنا الدوليين  لكن هذا الأمر أصبح
أكثر صعوبة بسبب معاملة إيران العنيفة
للمتظاهرين
وأفعالهم المستمرة التي تزعزع الاستقرار
في المنطقة ،
ستقرر الحكومة الأجنبية أفضل السبل
للإجابة ومن الواضح أن الحل
السلمي هو الأفضل ولكنك تعلم
أنني لست متأكدًا من أنه من العدل  اطلب من
الأوكرانيين الحضور إلى طاولة المفاوضات
في نفس الوقت
الذي تتعرض فيه بلادهم لهجوم
عنيف.  لقد سلط السلام أو
الازدهار دون اتخاذ إجراءات بشأن تغير
المناخ ، وبالفعل الغزو الروسي
لأوكرانيا ، الضوء على
أهمية تحولنا جميعًا إلى أشكال أكثر أمانًا
وأنظف وأرخص من الطاقة
وإزالة اعتمادنا على الوقود الأحفوري
[تصفيق]